Hello YouTube. So um as you know there's
been a ceasefire announced
um
in the Middle East
and uh many of you are curious as to
what this ceasefire means.
Well, I still believe that the United
States, Israel, and Iran are fully
committed to war.
And the ceasefire, it's really about
attempting to shape the narrative around
this war, trying to control the terms,
trying to determine how the war war will
be fought.
Um, so for Iran, for the Ayatollah, it's
very important that the Iranian people
understand
that Iran is forced into
this war. Um, in his speech to the
Iranian people right after the um, US
bombing,
um, he credited the economy between Iran
and the United States. Iran is a nation
dedicated to peace. United States is a
nation dedicated to war.
The Iranian people live the truth. The
American people tell the lie.
And the Iranian people will do all it
can to achieve peace.
But if forced to defend sovereignty, if
forced to defend uh their faith, then
the Iranian people will fight to the
death. The Iranian people will never
surrender.
But if an opportunity for peace presents
itself, then the Iranian people, the
Iranian nation, the atollah will grasp
at that opportunity.
Um
Trump
um did launch the um attacks against
Iran,
but he's trying to create the narrative
that this is happening not because this
is what he wants, but because he's
forced to do so by the globalists, by
the deep state, by the American empire.
He himself is a person who only aspires
for world peace. Um but these
wararmongers, these neocons within his
administration,
um who are embedded in the deep state
and who have tentacles all around the
world,
they are undermining him and forcing him
to act against Iran. But he will fight
for the American people. He will fight
for world peace. And um that's why he is
trying as hard as he can to broker a
peace deal between Israel and Iran.
Um
both Trump and the Aatollah
can do this. um can try to be the
peacemakers because they know that
Netanyahu
will continue to push for war that
Israel will continue to be the aggressor
in this uh war. So, Israel is really a
scapegoat. But it's really important um
for us to understand that um all three
leaders, Trump, Yatollah, and Nanyahu
are committed to war for different
reasons.
So, in today's talk, I want to explain
to you what's really driving these three
individuals. Why are they committed to
war? And what do they want from this
war?
And for us to understand this, I want to
introduce to you a new concept. It's
called the messianic calling.
Each of these individuals, Trump, the
Aatollah, and Nanyahu, see themselves as
historical messianic figures. They're on
a mission from God to save the world, to
save their people, to deliver their
people into the promised land.
And if we we need to understand that
this is ultimately what's driving them.
Um not fame, not power,
um
nothing but this misinic calling. that's
what's really um driving them. So let me
explain what this meant calling is by
explain explain to you it's three major
characteristics.
The first major characteristic is that
um when you truly believe that you are
on a mission from God, that you are the
chosen one, that you are the prophet,
that God smiles on you, you have access
to divine energy.
What is divine energy? Um let me give
you an example.
Maybe you're a mother and you're taking
your three-year-old into the forest.
If you get lost and you're wandering the
woods and then suddenly a black bear
pounces on you. Well, as a mother,
what's going to happen is and and you
could be petite, you could be weak.
What's going to happen is you suddenly
when your child is under attack, under
threat, you will find unlimited energy,
strength, and courage to fight off this
bear and you will succeed. And we know
because um there's been a couple adults
um like this. So a mother's love for a
child is one of the strongest forces in
the world. Now to understand divine
energy just multiply this mother's love
for her child by about a million and you
can understand how energized how
motivated how powerful
um people with imaging calling feels.
The classic example is Trump, right? So
Trump during the campaign season, he
would get about like four or five
o'clock in the morning, do a lot of
tweets, watch a lot of TV. He get he
would get on on his plane and go to a
campaign rally where he would talk
endlessly for a couple hours. Then he
would get back on the plane and then fly
somewhere else and do another rally. And
then he would do another rally um in
front of 50,000 people. And then um he
would watch the news and then he go he
go to bed, sleep soundly and get up the
next morning do it again for 2 3 4
months. Um and you have to ask yourself
why is he so energetic? He's 79. Why is
he so motivated? Um, I mean, he's not in
the best health in the world because he
he eats McDonald's all the time and he's
clearly obese for his for for his age.
Um but none of this matters because
um his faith in his mission, the fact
that he knows that he's been chosen by
God to complete
um his mission
um that fills him with an infinite
energy
um and that's where his strength comes
from.
The second characteristic um of people
who are um filled with the messianic
calling is that they are absolutely
fearless.
Um they know that because God has chosen
them, God will protect them
and so no bullets can harm them. Okay.
So Trump um so the classic example again
is Trump. Um he was um almost
assassinated at at Butler, Pennsylvania.
And remember how um even though the
bullet came close to him, he was still
able to get up and pump his fist and
shout to the people, "Fight, fight,
fight." Okay, it's this absolute
fearlessness. They know that God will
always protect them. But also, um even
if they were to die, they would go
straight to heaven and be with God.
They're one of the elect.
And then finally um
their bodies no longer matter. Their
bodies are just vessels for this divine
energy uh to be transplanted on earth.
When they die when their vessel this
vessel breaks and it fills the followers
with divine energy as well they become
martyrs and their followers will
complete the mission on their behalf. So
they've transcended death. They've
transcended this material world. They
are now ideas. They are now faith.
They're now um inspiration
uh for their followers. And so they are
and therefore they are immortal. They're
eternal. And they are invincible.
Um the third characteristic of people
with me calling
um um is
the pers persecution complex. The idea
is how do you know that you are one of
the elect? How do you know that God has
chosen you? It's because society, the
world, everyone around you persecutes
you. Right? So again the classic example
is Trump. Trump survived two
impeachments. Um in his first term, the
deep state um um filled um his cabinet.
John Bolton, Mike Pompeo, Nikki Haley.
Um
everyone was part of the deep state and
they undermined him. In fact, you had
generals brag about how they
intentionally
um
disobeyed Trump's orders. In fact, you
had one general, Mark Millie, who um
told the Chinese government, "Don't
listen to Trump. He's not really in
charge. If you have any issues, call us
directly." Okay? So, they were
undermining him. Uh the media every day
was lambasting him, cursing him. The
whole world was cursing him or laughing
at him, right? The European elite was
laughing at him. Remember when um Trump
was talking about the Nordstream
pipeline and how it it would cause
German dependency on Russian oil? Those
German um ambassadors were at the back
of United Nations laughing their heads
off at uh at Trump. Um after he left
office um Trump had to survive lawfare,
right? They raided his home at Mer Lago.
um they try to bankrupt him. They try to
throw him in prison for extremely
spirious um offenses.
So
um Trump feels he's persecuted, but
that's good for him. That energizes him
because it makes him feel that God is
testing him. God wants to know, do you
truly believe in your mission? Are you
truly committed to your mission? And
through this persecution process um
Trump will develop more and more faith,
more strength, more power. Um this
divine energy is filling him and and um
this divine energy will allow him to
fulfill his mission. Let's look at the
Ayatollah. Um right now um the world's
most sophisticated intelligence agency,
Mossad, is hunting him. They want to
assassinate him. the American military,
the most powerful military in human
history, uh, with their precision bombs,
with their satellite um, technology,
they're hunting the Alatollah as well.
And the at 86. So given all this, how
does the Alatia feel right now? And the
answer is he feels ecstatic. He's never
been more alive. He's never been more
energetic. He's never felt more vibrant
in his life. Um, he feels as though the
moment he's been waiting for all his
life,
um, the moment he's dreamt of all his
life, the opportunity to kill the great
Satan, it is now before him. And so, um,
he's not going to die. Um, and if you
ask him to go run a marathon tomorrow,
he could do so. That's the power of
divine energy combined with the pers
persecution complex. Natanya was the
same situation. Netanyahu,
his country, Israel, it's it's divided.
Um there are all these corruption
charges against him and his family. And
right now he um as long as he's in
office, he's immune from these charges.
Um but the moment that this war stops,
then he would face um corruption charges
and he would probably thrown in prison.
Um he's not faced by any of this. um he
knows that this persecution it's all a
sign that God favors him and this
persecution
uh will ultimately give him the strength
the faith to fulfill his divine mission
on earth.
So now what I want to talk about is
what exactly is the divine mission? How
do each individual perceive their divine
mission? So I'll start with theata
because that's that's fairly simple. Um
the Persians their belief system is
combination of both Zorashinism as well
as Shia Muslim.
Zorashinism is the world's first
esquetological
uh religion and in it is a moral
clarity. The world is divided between
good and evil, between light and dark,
between the truth and the lie. And this
is the very structure of the cosmos.
Um, and these two forces have been have
been at war since the beginning of time.
Eventually, these forces will meet in a
final climatic battle. And this at this
point, we humans we must make the
decision as to what force to join. Will
we fight for the side of good or we
fight for the side of evil? Uh and
clearly the Ayatollah believes that he
must unite the Muslim world uh and have
them fight on the side of good against
the great evil, the great Satan, which
is the United States and their vassal
state um Israel. The Shia Muslim
religion is one that believes that
suffering
uh persecution and sacrifice, it's all
part of your faith. If you truly believe
then you will suffer and you'll
sacrifice yourself. So
the is willing to die for what he
believes in. Um he's willing to die for
his faith. That for him would be the
greatest honor. So the Ayatollah what he
wants um it's pretty clear.
He wants to lure the great Satan into
Iran. He wants to lure the great Satan
into his lear where he will take his
flaming sword and stab the great Satan
to death. Thus freeing his people from
oppression, from persecution, from
suffering and and by killing the great
Satan, he will save his people and save
the world. Okay, that's that's the
divine mission of the Ayatollah.
Donald Trump, what is his divine
mission? Well, he wants to make America
great again. So why is America not
great? The reason why is for the past
100 years, America has been co-opted by
the globalists
and America has been forced to engage in
these forever wars in the Middle East um
that has killed thousands of good
American soldiers.
And this was done at the behests of the
globalists.
Um these globalists have also forced
open American borders and let in
millions and millions of illegal
immigrants in order to corrupt America
in order to destroy civil society in
America. These globalists also have in
the school curriculum
infested
um the teachings of young children with
multiculturalism with work politics with
DEI diversity inclusion
um equity these ideas so these ideas
globalism liberalism and
multiculturalism are cancers
on the body of the American Republic.
And you can't negotiate with cancers.
You can't wait for cancers to die out.
You must purge these cancers from the
body body of American republic with
blood and fire.
So the divine mission for Trump is to
destroy the American empire by rolling
it into an unwinable war against Iran.
But not only that, but to compel the
American people to rise up against their
globalist oppressors
and overthrow
them, to remove America from the world
and to achieve its manifest destiny,
which is basically control over North
America, which is which is the promised
land, uh, which is what God promised to
the Americans. And once America
recognized that it should not interfere
in global affairs, Europe, Asia, Africa,
who cares? They're hopeless. Um, once
America is able to restore its
Republican soul and spirit, then America
will be great again. And Donald Trump,
his mission is to lead the American
people um in the revolution against the
global elite and to restore the American
republic. Okay, that's Donald Trump.
Then you have Benjamin Netanyahu.
Um for Benjamin Netanyahu, um like many
many um Israelis, um they believe that
the golden age of the Jewish people was
Kingdom of David, which which occurred
about 3,000 years ago. That was when um
Israel, the nation was free,
independent, unified and supreme in the
Middle East. It was a time of peace and
prosperity for the world. But after the
kingdom kingdom of David um collapsed um
um
Israel has been attacked by its
neighbors and has been dismembered and
has become a vassel state.
Um first the Assyrians and Babylon
Babylons came to dismember uh Israel.
Then Israel became a vassal state to the
Persians. Then after the Persians came
the Tomies of Egypt and after that were
the Seucid Empire. Um the Jews were able
to rebel against Seucid Empire and
establish um the Ma the ring of the
Mcabes. But that didn't last very long
because the Romans came right after
that. And the Romans were brutal. The
Romans um killed many many uh Jews and
they exiled the Jews from Jerusalem. Um
their whole their their their place of
worship um and they destroyed the um
second temple.
So um the Romans were extremely brutal.
Um um in the 7th century, the Islamic
Caliphate restored the Jews to
Jerusalem, but they were still not
masters of their own land. Um so the
entire project of Israel is to return to
the glory days of the kingdom of David.
And now
is a historical opportunity to achieve
that. Um the only uh opposition against
est reestablishing the kingdom of David
is Iran and the United States. And if
both can be destroyed in a cat
cataclysmic war, then you will have the
restoration of the kingdom of David.
Israel will be a unified nation again.
All Jews can now return to Israel and
Israel can be the light of all nations
which is um what all which is what the
nation aspires to.
Of course, this raises a really
interesting question.
For the empire of Israel uh to be born,
the empire of America needs to be
destroyed. So, why would America just
sit back and let this happen? Um, why
would the global elite allow for
uh Israel to become dominant in the
Middle East? Remember, the center of
global trade is the Middle East. Most of
the world's oil is in the Middle East.
Well,
um I think Israel will achieve
um its ambition. And the reason why is
there are certain elements of the
American Empire. There are certain
elements of the global elite that want
the Kingdom of David to be restored.
They want the American Empire to be
destroyed and to leave the Middle East.
um they they want to help Netanyahu
achieve his messianic calling.
These elements are what we can loosely
call Christian Zionists. They believe
that for Jesus to return,
the nation of Israel has to be
reconstituted. They have to uh rebuild
their temple and they have to call back
all the Jews from around the world. And
there has to be a final battle between
Israel and the world. And they believe
it. They believe that it is their mess
calling to make this prophecy happen.
Um and you hear this and you think this
is all really silly. But um let me tell
you two things. The first thing is
this plan, this prophecy has been in
place for centuries.
Um, this Christian Zionist project has
been around
um, ever since the Protestant
Reformation
and um, these people have been patiently
planning and waiting for today. That's
the first thing. The second thing you
need to know is
there's a man who actually conceived
this Christian Zionist project who built
the intellectual foundations
for Christian Zionism.
And this man um you know his name but
you may not really know who he is. His
name is Isaac Newton. And you know that
yeah he is the founder of calculus and
he conceived the foundations for
classical mechanics in physics but you
don't know who the real historical Isaac
Newton is. The real historical Isaac
Newton saw himself as a prophet with a
mezanite calling um to understand the
mind of God and to prepare for the
return of Jesus. And um as you probably
know Isaac Newton was a very very smart
man. So, um, in my next video, I'm going
to talk about the real historical Isaac
Newton and what his plan is. Because
once you understand all this, then
what's happening in the Middle East
makes a lot more sense.